hey daddy how's it going dude pretty
good
it's a pleasure to meet you it's same
here man uh i apologize that out of all
the folks
that vlog chaps you got stuck with me
you i
you are truly up for a challenge my dude
but i i really appreciate you to advance
your patience and
uh i'm sure folks watching will you know
you know also appreciate your wisdom oh
of course well it's a
big honor for me uh to teach you so
don't worry about that at all i'm that's
this is what i do for a living so
it's a real pleasure now with that being
said i am of the russian school of chess
teaching so i'm going to roast the hell
out of you but
we'll get to that later man i want it i
want it you know
be fierce i'm i'm down until i cry you
know a little
quite a little you know screaming a
little loud you know a little easier on
me
yeah i'm ready dude so so what i mean do
you want i mean so so dude
i read your bio and and dude you've been
you've been playing
chess all your life which is which is
that's me since you were six
yep so my my dad and my brother kind of
jointly taught me my brother's
four years older than me and i actually
remember where i learned chess
it was at this birthday party and you
know i played lego monopoly and stuff
with my brother
and my brother decided to bring along a
chess set because right
you know we would get bored and that's
when it started i mean it wasn't too
glamorous at first
i get you know the crap beat out of me
by my brother but
about a year or so in it started
replacing stuff like lego it was always
just chest chest chest
wow and you know i've always been
kind of a balanced person so i went to
school my whole life now it's become
very fashionable for like chess
prodigies to to be homeschooled and sort
of go full steam ahead
especially in the us but i was sort of
always in school always out of their
interests so
it's always allowed me just to not get
burnt out and to keep my interest going
wow oh man dude this is it is it's in
your
it's it courses through my veins how did
you uh
learn chest or what was your sort of
experience
oh god oh you're gonna you're gonna
cringe okay here we go not at all
um last year there was a
a paid promotion for uh this and new
amazon show like uh
god what's it called um good and evil or
something along those lines but anyway
uh it was me and
and jericho we did like you know real
life chess
together at south by southwest and we're
both being like you know
uh we were both being basically helped
by
by by the boys at chess.com so
so on my side i think it was oh god
uh i want to make sure i don't butcher
butcher his name but he's the owner of
chess.com
uh and uh he was he was on my side
versus jericho and and you know we each
won a game it was pretty fair it's
pretty fun
and and my only training before them was
using the chess kids app for maybe like
two hours but that was a year ago i
haven't played since
and uh and yesterday i played uh
uh trading a little bit on stream and
eventually i pulled some viewers on and
i basically just asked them questions as
they played
and so at this point i've got a good
sense of
what what pieces can go where and how
and that's where i am
well i think you sold yourself short
that actually that's not bad at all
um and uh so i think i think we'll take
sort of a multi-pronged approach i think
we can start with sort of an overview of
some basic strategies and you know i
could
you know my first thought i'll put you
straight into the pool and start
watching you play but
that's like you know you're learning how
to fly a plane and i'm like how about
you fly a 787 and i just watch you and
then i'll critique you
if you land um so we'll see
we'll start with sort of the
instructional component and then when
when you and when you end up playing we
might do like a slow game oh thank you
chess bro thank you eric for the raid of
the
party of 602. amazing so um
basically we'll start with that
instruction come on then when you play
it'll be a slow game
and essentially as you're making your
moves we'll
talk the moves through together right um
and you know chess.com i think will then
refund the points to
to those poor souls whom you beat up on
i mean i know you don't even need me to
beat up on those souls but
i'll just be there kind of in the
background watching
[Music]
that's good so this is the starting
position let's say that you're playing
white there are two things exactly two
things that you need to master in order
to become a grandmaster master these two
things
and there's nothing else that you need
to know the first is
how not to blunder pieces or how not to
hang pieces
and the second is how to put your pieces
in good positions that's literally all
the chess is really about
so it sounds pretty pretty easy sounds
sound straightforward i'm sure there's a
bazillion level levels beyond that but
i'm ready that sounds like
like an easy start i'm in everything
kind of branches out from those two
now when you look at the starting
position the bottom line
strategy in the opening right and it's
referred to as the opening for obvious
reasons it's the first you know 10 15
moves of a chess game
right is to do the second thing that i
told you so so basically to take your
pieces
and put them place them on squares where
they are accomplishing a very specific
task
okay now what do i mean by task
what i mean by task is generally they're
either contributing to an attack on your
opponent's king
right or they're occupying a lot of
space and in order for a piece to occupy
a lot of space it has to be
and i'm going to draw this with arrows
somewhere
in this middle square that's kind of
called the center
you got it and the force and maybe
you've heard a lot of this so feel free
to stop me if i'm
droning on too much about something you
already know
but basically i've drawn the center and
i've drawn the four center squares d
they're referred to as d are you
familiar at all with chest notation
like well like like d3 and or
uh i mean i i know of it but like if you
told me like i'd have to like take him
and go like
f and then prove my finger up until like
five you know like so
i know of it but i i don't like i'm not
instinctive about it yet
that's totally fine so i'll i'll try to
kind of throw it with an arrow or
give you time to process it if i do name
a square so what i've drawn here is the
center if you put pieces
on squares roughly around this square of
the board
then by definition those pieces and what
i really mean are knights and bishops
right are going to be controlling the
maximum number of squares
so and you know again i know i'm giving
you a lot to start with we'll
we'll put this into practice shortly
right right
now you might be okay great let me
develop my freaking bishops i can't
develop them they have these stupid
pawns in the way so that's why
you start the game always with the
movement of the pawn and you start with
the movement of one of the two center
pawns the move that
most beginners play as one e4 right
so could you tell me what this move
accomplishes which piece does it unlock
yes so this one i actually learned
yesterday from some very you know
smart good players in my own chat um so
what you do over here is i don't have to
wait for me to mark but basically the
queen and the bishop both are like free
to kind of like you know be released
from the back row right
exactly i i mean i could make you
capable of marking
and it might glitch out so but let me
try no no worries
it's okay i i i i can point it out all
good not risky we're good
gotcha so exactly queen and the bishop
are opened
right and generally black responds with
e5
this is not the only possible move in
this position in fact as you get better
there's 20 possible moves in the
starting position the move that a lot of
grandmasters play for example is the
move c5
that's called the sicilian defense i
have no idea why i think
because it was first played in sicily or
by an italian chess club
a lot of these names of openings really
have nothing to do with the
person who first played them right um
chess is crazy if you didn't know better
chess players are crazy
you know this is like a big mental
institution keep keeping you guessing
until the very very end i hear you
exactly so
but but this move should make sense to
you basically the pawn controls one of
the four key central squares
right um it doesn't open up any pieces
yet not it doesn't open up any bishops
but
again as you get better there's there's
kind of principles that you can violate
and rules that you can bend
but let's assume for the purposes of
this that black does play e5
right now the first kind of opening
principle that you should be aware of is
generally you want to develop a knight
first
or the knights first and then the
bishops later now that can be bent a
little bit
but in this specific position it's a
good idea to develop one of the knights
now could you tell me
when you look at this sort of
intuitively which night do you feel like
developing and where do you feel like
putting it
uh g1 and i would put it on f3 so they
can maybe like you know
knock out that pawn if it wanted to or
put it like you know make it feel like
it's afraid or something or i don't know
is would that be the move it would
absolutely be the move it breathes
immediate
facts i think most of your opponents
will just give up if you make this move
they won't extend the game anymore
that's like this guy is clearly a gm
i'm done so
knight f3 is the best move now knight c3
exists this is called the vienna game
right um a lot of good things happened
in vienna apparently
but like you said it doesn't attack the
pawn so this move has its own reasons
but
again you should play knight f3 now
black develops
his knight to c6 and guards the pawn
right and this leads me to sort of the
second thing that is going to be a
struggle for you and that we're going to
work on which is basically identifying
pieces that are hanging
and identifying pieces that are defended
right so if a pawn or a piece
has an equal number of attackers and
defenders
then you cannot capture that pawn or a
piece normally okay
so what i mean by this is the pawn on e5
has one attacker that would be the
knight
and one defender that would be black
slam but if you take
you basically forfeit one of the
attackers so now black has more
defenders than white has attackers and
black can just take the knight
right so i lost my knight and they're
only and
they're only down a pawn right you have
yeah so you have an extra knife for upon
are you familiar with sort of
relative piece values which pieces are
stronger than other pieces
not super well i understand the queen is
probably the most powerful
and uh the the knight is the most unique
in movement
and and uh but i i'd say
i don't have like a clear like ranking
in my mind of like you know which are
the ones i have the greatest value or
like if you ask me between like the
bishop and
and well between the bishop and rook i
would say the bishop
i'm not 100 sure mm-hmm unacceptable get
out of the call just kidding so
basically you're absolutely well the
king is
you know just like those old visa
commercials the penny is worth you know
pen is worth five dollars the king is
priceless that belongs in its own
category
right because if the king is it's kind
of the lamest piece
but the gang is chug made of the game is
over so it also is the most important
piece
now the queen is the most powerful piece
and there are ace there is a system of
point values that are assigned that
helps beginners kind of understand
relative power i don't put a lot of
stock in it but i'll share it with you
i think the queen is normally assigned a
value of eight or nine points depending
on the rank
on the system somewhere in that
neighborhood the rook is actually the
second most powerful piece
oh interesting and the rook generally is
assigned
a value of five points
again don't take this to you know think
about this for the rest of my rook is
worth five points this is just for
context
right and the reason why is is this can
be kind of reflected mathematically the
rooks move
just have a higher range of motion than
the bishops the rooks don't move
diagonally
but they can achieve more in less amount
of time than the bishops the bishops
only move diagonally
uh okay i get it so the bishops will
always be restricted to like you know a
single color when they're moving around
whereas the rook could
theoretically like you know if not a
pose could hit any
any single space in the board fantastic
observation yeah the white square bishop
can never migrate to the dark square so
it's like completely
blind and deaf as to all the action
going on in the dark squares
so that's that's that's a problem you
have two bishops to begin with but if
one of them are traded and this already
gets very advanced
but because you pointed this out if one
of the bishops gets traded
then you might have a problem going on
in the dark squares like if the dark
squared bishop gets straight because you
don't have anything to occupy those dark
squares with
squares with right and the queen the way
you need to realize
to understand the queen is that the
queen is kind of it's the war general
it's not the minion it's not the
foot soldier it's the war general in the
background directing the action and it's
only going to lead into the war
if you know the battering rams of
basically
cleared the gates and made a ruin out of
your opponent's position
right look i get that the [ __ ] i don't
know if you've seen
the movie searching for bobby fischer um
amazing chess movie
highly recommend it got it um but in
this movie this it's about this boy who
who learns a real story based on a true
story his ways josh wadeskin and he's
learning chess
and a lot of kids in general they really
want to develop their freaking queen
when they start
they feel really empowered when they put
their queen right in their opponent's
grill
right but the problem with that is that
when the when this queen gets attacked
you cannot afford to lose your queen
because
again it's the most powerful piece so
putting it out on the
at the start of the game makes the queen
a huge liability and you do not want
that
right um and again i'm sorry to drown on
so much
i mean no yeah i know it's i'm laying
out a lot of things i i would definitely
let you know that like i just need a
moment to absorb it so far
i'm good that makes total sense and i'm
i'm i'm
i'm weirdly like you know i'm i'm caught
up so this is this is i'm
i'm good perfect i appreciate that so
basically
going back to our key position here
knights and bishops are approximately
equivalent at three points
right that is because as you pointed out
both
well the knights have a truly unique
movement they can jump over other pieces
now the bishop's
movement is shared by the movement of
the queen but the bishop is considered a
very long range piece it can jump from
one side of the board to the other
in one fell swoop the knights are kind
of they have short legs
right you know they're not good at if
you assign the knight a task of being
involved
on the other side of the board it's
going to take the night three or four
moves to get there and that's a lot of
time
when you stay in the context of a chess
game sure
you know so but it's compensated by the
unique movement so three points each
bishops and knights and the pawns
intuitively enough are worth one point
each so they're the least
quote unquote powerful piece pawns are
also pieces
you know they are a legitimate piece but
bonds are in their own category because
and i assume you're familiar entirely
with the movement of the pawn you can
start by going two squares forward at
the initial square
after that you can only move one square
the time and it captures diagonally
there's also a rule called on passant um
which even some pretty advanced players
are not aware but we'll get to that
eventually it's not important right now
got it so to recap queen is worth 89
rooks are worth five
knights and bishops are worth three and
pawns are worth one thank you grandpa
for the sub
um see someone named grandpa found
that's so instructive he subscribed
so that's awesome hey dude
so to go back to this position what
comes to mind
as a sensible developing move here for
white
for white right now uh i feel like this
is let me see so if the knight's over
there
i mean i guess what i've seen others do
and just kind of have like more
if i was trying to control more of the
board uh i guess the first thing i would
do is i would take the
the bishop from from uh f1 and move it
to
uh to uh e2 just kind of
have it like you just have something
kind of like at least that diagonal over
there if anyone tries to kind of get in
my
my firing range i can go in there and
and and show some threat
so you're talking sort of about this
diagonal kind of
uh or more towards the the more towards
um
a6 uh-huh the f1 a6 diagonal yes
right yeah so what's the right answer
there so bishop b2 is not a bad move i'd
give this move sort of a b
you know it's it's decent it does the
job of developing the bishop but if you
notice the bishop here
right when it sits on its initial square
it already controls
this diagonal oh yeah you're right
there's like there's no real value in
kind of like it's not being blocked
anymore and it's not really
there's no i'm not really if anything
i'm just blocking the queen
at that point good point and so what you
need to do with this bishop is since
it's already controlling this tango you
need to take it and put it on a square
where it's controlling
maybe another diagonal or it's
pressuring a certain square
next to black's king and there is
actually one square
that achieves that oh would that be
uh let me see would that be c4
that would be c4 this is called the
italian game so whatever the italians do
must be good
um food chess openings you know sicilian
italian
really they've made a big mark on the
chess world oh yeah
but in all in all seriousness um the
bishop in addition to controlling our
initial diagonal
is putting pressure on the pawn on f7 ah
this pawn on f7 is considered the
weakest square
on the entire chessboard thanks chicken
commander so
why is that because it's only guarded by
the king and so it's an access point to
black's game now could you tell me this
is white actually threatening to capture
the spawn of this bishop is that
something he's gonna do on the next move
uh no it'd be dumb right because they
would just throw away their their bishop
and the king would just be up by like
one spot i mean i guess they'd forfeit
their their castling or
or whatever but it doesn't seem like
that would be the play right exactly
so right and you're already grasping a
lot of things in that same so you
understand already the concept of a
sacrifice i'm sure you've heard that
word before in a chess context what does
that sacrifice mean
sacrifice means giving up a piece or
giving up a piece of greater value for a
piece of lesser value
in order to achieve another aim for
example in order to weaken the king
in order to gain a very important square
for one of your other pieces that's what
makes chess in my opinion such a
beautiful game and aggressive players
players who have what's called an
attacking style right are players who
really like to sacrifice their pieces
now sometimes
sacrifices can be unsound you can decide
to sacrifice let's say a queen for a
knight
and you said i'm getting his king out
into the middle of the board and i'm
gonna rip that king to shreds
but it turns out that you've
miscalculated something and the king
escapes and you're you end up down a
queen which is a huge disadvantage
right so not all sacrifices are clear
cut and that's what introduces the
concept of risk
into the chest and the funny thing is
people in my chat recently in the chest
role there has been this kind of
meme about something called the jerome
gambit and a gambit
just like in real life refers to an
opening where you actually sacrifice
something
right this move exists and it has a name
it's called the jerome gambit
named after an american chess player the
last name jerome
right was jerome a very good player and
they're gonna come after me for saying
this
not really oh boy he was a coffee house
player
he was a cigar smoking you know i i'm
gonna just
miss them up you know so he liked
sacrifice he didn't play seriously and
so he liked making this move
ah so i guess they would go in there and
now the jerome gambit continues knight
takes c5
what why does this move look bad just to
some practice
i i mean what does it look bad like
if if we were to make that move yes so
is knight takes c5 an advice does this
just win a pawn
or can black do something here you you
are in striking range of of
of taking uh their king right like just
one move away
it's check exactly so you are attacking
the king
and the only way to deal with the check
there are three
one is to block the check which you
cannot do with the knight because there
is no piece that blocks the knight
that's as you mentioned why the knight
is such a strong piece
right the second method of dealing with
a check intuitively enough is to move
the king away
for example here and the third way is to
capture
the piece that is delivering the check
right
is that third method possible here
absolutely right you have the opposing
knight on
on c6 that could just take it next turn
if they wanted to just tell like to
recapture there right exactly and that's
what you would do in black is up not one
but
two pieces now now there is an idea we
won't go further here because
we're a little bit whaley but white does
have a way of recapturing
one of these two pieces which makes the
jerome gamba playable
it's still not a great opening though
but just to introduce you to the concept
of sacrifices that's a legitimate thing
got it so to continue we've developed a
night we've developed a bishop
are you familiar with the concept of
castling
yes but i'd love to love to hear more i
understand it's basically the
kind of like the rook is like the
bodyguard comes in pushes the
the king to the side and like you know
i'll take this bullet for you and
and you kind of like you know as long as
there's no one in the way so right now
uh the the rook at uh h1
could hop into i believe e1 and then the
king would go to oh no maybe maybe
one yeah f1 and they're in the king
would be g1 okay
okay yes there we go that's exactly
right i don't know what the origins of
castling are i don't think castling
existed in the
earliest versions of chess but whoever
invented this is a genius
because it kind of changes the game
entirely
and you're exactly right in describing
what castling does it really does two
things first of all the rokex is the
bodyguard
and also the king is now behind this
defensive cocoon of these three pawns
right and so you might say well isn't it
the same thing when the king is instead
of not really because you've already
pushed one of the pawns in front of the
king forward by definition
weakening the king right and the third
thing to notice about castling
notice this pawn on f7 and this
equivalently weak pawn on f2
right as you pointed out when you castle
now this is defended by the rook
so it's not as weak of a point as it is
when the king is in the center
right and finally what you can do when
you've already castled and tucked your
king away is you can work on opening up
the center
and you don't have to worry one bit
about your king suffering the
consequences
of ripping open the center right right
he won't be in the line of fire anymore
because he's all castled up in
the corner there exactly now is the king
safe forever absolutely not
many many chess games have been won by
an attack against the castle king and
hopefully we'll get to that at some
point
um so castling here is a good move um
could you give me a
solid alternative here in terms of
developing more of your undeveloped
pieces
uh wouldn't you just uh could i move
let's say two well
2d up one space so that like i've seen a
lot of players kind of do this like this
almost like pyramid of like
like like you know pawns where it's like
you know one is top like one is one
piece of space head in the middle and
it's got
kind of flanked by two behind them and
like you know jason rose
is would that be a move
it would and actually that's the move i
was looking for because it opens up the
other bishop
ah there we go right i think i'm gonna
give you the honorary grandmaster title
for that you'll be teaching me
and yeah so this is called a pawn chain
for
right relatively obvious reason one pawn
defends the next
right so you know they're like a conga
line and that's pretty good because each
spawn is now protected and that's kind
of something you want to aim for that's
a little bit advanced but
you know it doesn't hurt to keep that in
the back of your mind sure
um so black usually develops his own
knight
and here again you have a pretty wide
choice of developing
a bunch of your piece you can develop
your knight to c3
right sensible you could absolutely
castle
but the move that i'd like you to make
there is a third option of development
and you should be able to identify the
piece that hasn't been developed yet
that i haven't mentioned yet
the real question is which square do you
put this piece on
oh wow oh i'm actually kind of a little
bit a little bit
lost here so i'm not going to touch
those three pawns they're kind of
defending each other there basically we
just talked about
um the idea is that the the king can
theoretically be
castled to like the let's say the right
corner so also the left side is where we
might want to develop
perfectly good move yeah right so um
i don't maybe we'd maybe we'd move
oh god which pieces are still on their
initial square sorry
didn't mean a good job yeah i was gonna
guess a2 the pawn over there to kind of
like try and like you know
like it might be time to just release
the like the rook on the right
and h1 is going to be dedicated to kind
of like castling at least initially
i forget the other rook which you said
was a very powerful piece that's when
we're going to want to get to action
eventually so i guess
would it be moving to uh
two a two two oh that's what's going on
like this two three or two four yeah
something like that yes or like this to
open up the rook
so i actually like your thinking here
and and this demonstrates a certain
depth already the fact that you pay
attention to the rook is good now
however however just like the queen is
sort of the war general that comes in at
the ends
right the rook is a it's an incredibly
powerful piece in the open board because
it moves side to side and up and down
but it's very clunky you know it's
almost like
the road conditions are not i was going
to compare the rook to a tank that would
be a terrible comparison that would be
the opposite of what i'm trying to say
the rook is like you know a rolls-royce
down you know a bosnian road right now
right like there's a lot of potholes in
this road
i don't know why i said bosnian run i
have no idea of all the wars that i can
compare it to i choose some random ones
um i'd totally get that one sorry i was
a history major so
i i'm i'm intolerable with my analogies
but can you see that let's say i even
let you put
bring the rook out right the pawn the
white pawn is blocking the rook from
accessing the other side of the board
this pawn needs to be pushed further and
even if i let you push your pawn all the
way up
and you develop your rook to a4 and you
feel like a beast for exactly one second
i say congratulations you've developed
your rook
but where is this rook going what is it
accomplishing really nothing right it's
staring at your own bishop
right does that kind of make sense no
not at all not at all because
it just makes it vulnerable for no
reason right exactly it would make it
vulnerable to attack by blacks pawns and
pieces and
which is fine as long as the piece is
accomplishing something but it's really
not right
so right what i would say is focus on
your knights and your bishops
knight c3 being one move but the other
piece we've left out is this bishop on
c1
right and where could that piece jump to
oh
that could theoretically let me see here
that could go to
let me see if so it obviously can't go
to
i guess uh towards three because uh i'm
sorry um
a3 because that's blocked off by the
pawn but it can go uh up towards there
so
so uh it would need to be let me see
here it can't be f4 because
oh it could be f4 because it's not would
it be it would not be vulnerable to the
knight there oh but it would be
vulnerable to
the other pawn bingo this pawn on e5
would be able to capture the bishop so
that would not be a good move
um would it be
5g it would it would yeah i like 4g
myself but select 5g in select cities
i actually it's actually called g5 you
actually say the
the letter first and then another number
um
and i think there's an old system of
notation where
you actually do say the square first but
the way that
most modern notation is like bishop to
g5 or knight to c3
gotcha gotcha and um got it
man the conspiracy theorists have gone
to town in my chat 5g oh no
coronavirus yeah um anyways
so bishop g5 now why is this move good
in addition to developing a piece sort
of as far as it'll go
it creates something called a pin
and the pin is defined as a situation
where one of your pieces immobilizes
an opponent's piece because that if that
piece moves
then you will capture a piece of greater
value so what does that mean
notice this diagonal oh yeah this is the
movement out of the way he's he's that
it's game over it's game over you've
captured the queen
right now people will do that at your
level they'll be like oh i'm a time
going to town on this pawn
and then they'll forget about the queen
and that's what i call tunnel vision
that's something that beginners often
have which is
inevitable where you're it's almost like
you
you know you're like you're seeing a
cookie or you're
and you're reaching for that cooking you
don't see any of the surroundings
and that's just gonna happen you're
gonna get attracted by a certain
possibility and you don't see the whole
part but that's okay
as long as you can kind of keep these
things in mind so this is a pin
right and it has to be a piece of
greater valve for example if i moved in
this situation
my bishop back to e7 right could you
explain why this
is no longer a pin
i mean it's not i mean they can just go
the other direction can they well i mean
why isn't that not a pin so move there
uh which part of the definition i
suppose
and i can repeat it does this not sort
of adhere to
oh the the piece is in the greater value
bingo exactly so this bishop is of the
same vowel so which means black's knight
can move away and if it does
and i'm not really making good moves for
black i'm forsaking my development here
right but i'm not also i'm not
blundering any pieces i'm not and it's
called hanging a piece when you put a
piece on a square where it can be
captured for no reason
right that's called hanging a piece and
that's like the
trademark of beginners do grandmasters
hang pieces absolutely i've hung pieces
before
because i mean the best chess players in
the world have hung pieces before i can
show you examples so
it's a huge it's a trademark of human
faults but it happens a lot more at the
beginner level when you're not entirely
familiar with peace movements yet
right and that's totally fine we'll work
on that so
black captures and this is called a
trade a trade is when two pieces of
approximately equal value have been
exchanged and
taken away from the board right and the
more pieces are exchanged and especially
if the queens are exchanged the closer
the game
gets to the final stage i'm sure you've
heard of this
this term called endgame yes an end game
is is the phase of the game when most
pieces have been taken off from the
board the definition is a loose one
there's no formal definition
the opening is basically when all of the
pieces are still getting developed in
the middle game or the mid game
is when all of the pieces have gotten
developed and both sides have most of
their pieces remaining on the board
most games that you play are going to be
decided actually either in the opening
or in the middle game
so once all of the pieces have been
developed and let's make some better
moves for black let's say black does the
same thing
d6 let's introduce the concept
of preventing your opponent from doing
something which is a little bit advanced
but i think you can
you're learning all this very very fast
now if it were black's move it's not but
if it were black to move
where would he develop this bishop that
i've just highlighted in red
based upon where you developed yours let
me see
um it would not
be uh let me see here
e6 right because he would just it would
just be vulnerable to the
the bishop at uh c4 right like but so
would it go down to
oh maybe um would be g4
it absolutely would and just to point
something out it would be vulnerable to
white's bishop but
what could black do if white captures
oh uh in that case that could be let me
see here they do capture
what would be the play here um looking
around
uh oh
nope uh there's no pawn oh the other
punk could just grab it right exactly
so this is a trade this is a trade and
is this a good trade or a bad trade
we'll get to that but it's nobody really
benefits from this specific trade
right but because you're in sort of the
training wheels phase you want to keep
most of the pieces on the board so that
you could better get acquainted with
how they move around and how they
cooperate so bishop g4 is perfect
right now let's say in your infinite was
grand masterly wisdom
you were playing with the white pieces
here and you were like i really don't
want black
my opponent to develop his bishop to the
super active square
right could you devise a way to prevent
his bishop from reaching this square let
me see so
i i can't move my my pawn at
h2 to h3 because it would just get oh
that makes no sense i would move on
uh would i move g
no so you didn't want to play h3 for
what reason
oh no well actually no it wouldn't be it
would just get
you theoretically just get devoured by
by the bishop then but then the other
pawn would just grab it
right exactly or which other piece could
take the bishop here
uh oh not the knight uh oh the rock of
course
exactly and this is why rooks are so
powerful when the pawn disappears from
the square in front of the rock
look at white's rook it's already
x-raying black stroke and it's already
on a really good square even though it's
only moved once
right so that's why i mentioned not to
artificially try to develop your rook
because rooks kind of jump
into the game by themselves when this
pawn
disappears from the board right and one
of the hardest things for you and to
begin will be to identify when
when there is a piece that can be
captured by any other piece
it's easy to get freaked out but what
you want to pay attention to is what
defends a particular piece so here once
you put this pawn on h3 it is called it
is defended by
the pawn on g2 and the rook on h1 so
it's defended twice it's very well
defended when a pawn is defended by
another pawn
that is the best form of defense because
by definition pawns are pieces of the
least value
so if a pawn that's offended by another
pawn is captured
then essentially by definition your
opponent's giving up a piece of
of greater value that would be a blunder
right but you're absolutely right you
saw the move so if the bishop comes out
to g4
then right you do what you just capture
with your pawn right
you got your mom yeah yeah that's right
so you're off a piece
i mean that would be a terrible move but
some people would would insist that
maybe a terrible move for them to put
their bishop over there right i mean
right yeah
okay got it now just to give you some
context at grand master level
if i were to blunder a piece against
another grandmaster
um i don't know if you're familiar with
too many transplanters like magnus or
hicaro
yeah yes so if i were to do to make this
movie against the car first of all he
would
ask me what i'm smoking if i played
bishop or i would not do the same thing
if i would slip or something right
um i would immediately resign the game
so being down a piece
at a high level is disastrous to such an
extent that i know that i'm going to
lose this game and i would resign i'd
put my king down
oh wow it's kind of like an in starcraft
if you know you lost like you know
like you know a base or whatever like
just even if you had units just know
like it's over so got it exactly and i
like the jamaican because a lot of
people come along when i say this to
them
like but what do you why would you
retire you have so many other pieces on
the board
but i'm like but you don't understand i
mean and just like the comparison that
you made i'm
not too familiar with starcraft but it's
like you lost a crucial part of your
army it doesn't matter that you have a
lot of other
freaking soldiers whatever you have
you're done you're done right
right yep yep um and but at your level
and not trying to d d distance no no no
no no no no no no no
do what you need to do man i am i'm a
scrub let's let's do this
essentially if you blunder a piece
you're down a piece that by no means
means the game is over so
right the real you know i would say
benchmark of when
you need to start worrying is like if
you blunder your queen
or you hang let's say a rook that's
pretty serious but you can still recover
from that
and i think that's what makes chess at
your level kind of fun is like you can
make a terrible move
but you're you you can rest assured in
the confidence that your opponent's
probably
also at some point later in the game
gonna make a terrible move in return
right but let's say that you play this
move h3
and black does a castle and you can
develop your knight could you remind me
which square
the knight is best developed to uh
that would be um c3 right it would be c3
and there's one more thing i want to
talk about before we sort of rehearse
this with the game
let's say black develops his bishop to
e6 right
now remember the concept of the well
first let's say black plays
h6 now without me introducing anything
about this move
could you tell me what this move
accomplishes
and what white should do in return so so
that puts threat on
on my bishop on on g5 right
exactly and what i should do um
if i if i take no i'm not taking the
taking the pawn makes no sense
i would just maybe like i would just i
would just back up i would go to uh
f4 maybe with the bishop just kind of
get out of its way so here's the deal
yes that would kind of be from the
frying pan into the fire because i have
another little
oh mrf here right and you i didn't see
that yes
so so if that's the case i mean i i lose
oh
i guess i would go down to uh h4 right
beautiful
and the benefit of this move versus
let's say going back all the way down to
t2
is that you maintain what is this called
again do you remember this term
oh uh pinning you're pinning the uh
right
bingo you're pinning the knight so you
maintain the pin why is the pin so good
because it just immobilizes your
opponent's pieces the knight can't move
and if the knight and another thing is
this is a little bit advanced but you
can say well can i
unpin myself by moving the queen and
then i can move the knight well that's
not a bad move but now you can actually
capture the knight
with your [ __ ] right and what happens
is that well there's no problem right
black captures with the pawn
but do you see anything about what's
happened to black's
what's called pawn structure do does
anything catch your eye about black's
pawns now
oh for sure like the wall is gone and
the king is just like
it's it's open it's like you know like
you know open for business right there
and
and a couple of moves can mean well the
king's vulnerable now right
exactly you said it and beca because
it's called a ruined pawn structure and
you know this is where i like to pull
out the world war ii comparisons but
instead i'll say like a
black spawn structure is like roman
ruins you know they're good for nothing
this kind of avenue toward the king is
open
and there's a set of term terms that
refer to this there's files
files are you know straight up and down
so this is the g
file right this is the eighth rank so
it's
rank and file and intuitively there's
diagonals and these are of course
diagonals
and in this situation again we're
extending this a little bit far but i
think
you know you're grasping things fast
enough to kind of understand this
you might ask well great black spawns
are like roman rose but
how do we actually access black's king
and this is where we we would initiate
what's called an
attack and an attack is simply a
concentrated
assault against your opponent's king
with the aim of in the end delivering
checkmate
right but you can't attack without any
pieces and queens in particular are very
very strong attackers for the obvious
reason that the queen's the most
powerful piece
notice what i said about the queens
earlier it's only really good
when the air has been cleared and the
gates have been crashed into and the
gates have definitely been crashed here
sure so she like you could essentially
send
the queen up the right side the uh the
the g uh
rank and like it'd be very tough to
oppose her right exactly or let's say
this square now there's a problem with
doing that right because you cannot
queen cannot jump over the knife right
so could you devise
a scheme where you nonetheless
are able to send the queen over to the
right side and the right side is also
called the king's
flank or the king side because the king
is on
e1 initially this encompasses the king
side and this encompasses
the queen side so could you send the
king
earth right the queen you don't send the
king anywhere here the queen to the
king's side how would you do that
let me see uh would the knight
just go to um d2
that would be a very good move opening
paving the path for the queen but let's
let me
let's say i wanted to kill two birds
with one stone right
and in addition to activating the queen
i also wanted this knight to participate
in the attack
oh oh i see so in that case you would
just maybe send them over to
um uh uh h4
dude that's that's a grandmaster level
move that's what i would play
knight h4 so the point i want to make is
even though you might consider yourself
a beginner the beautiful thing about
chess is you can appreciate
really good moves without knowing too
much about the game
because everything can be explained by
logic that's at least my sort of theory
no i i totally get that yeah absolutely
that's uh
yeah yeah the analogies i mean i've been
i've been great so i
i get like i can see this as like you
know like like a real battle you know
yeah and it's white's white's in great
shape now notice you haven't castled yet
and that's where in chess you have to
understand that sometimes the rules are
violated like you don't
always have to castle blindly sometimes
black has done something so wrong that
you can actually focus on punishing him
rather than doing things like castling
and here actually not castling is good
because white's king is safe
in the city let's say black just yeah
also i mean like
one of my questions i was gonna plan on
asking today is like like what's my
what's my my my my signal my red flag
that you know
you know bring bring the king down into
the bunker like how like what what does
it call this i guess
is it when the like if i'm not
controlling the center if if the other
player's controlling the center is that
one it's like all right you know like
bring you know
bring him in close castle up the king
yeah i mean normally
yeah sorry oh you're good yeah go for it
yeah i mean normally you know you castle
in most situations it it really i would
point it out as
you only don't castle if let's say your
opponent has
made something made a very bad move in
the opening let's say he's given his
queen up
then right he has nothing to attack you
with so you might keep your king in the
center of the board or a situation like
this where your opponent for example has
allowed
his pawns in front of his king to be
he's castled
and he's allowed his pawn structure to
be ruined and you want to focus on
attacking rather than
wasting time castling right so you're
going to castle in like 95
of the games and when we play you're
gonna you're gonna see that i will
advise you to castle
most of the time gotcha um
but last question here before we kind of
jump in
let's say black develops his own bishop
let's say to d7
um where could you and the key for you
to understand is before you
locate a square try to try to look at
the whole board and see if that square
is defended by any of
your opponent's pieces oh sure so where
would you put this queen how would you
activate it
um let's see i believe
the move would be uh i think it would
just be
h5 i mean i don't see any any immediate
threats around there
um yeah right
are you attacking any of your opponent's
pieces here
so let's say he makes an empty move
right
uh in this case what i when i just grab
the pawn in front of me i mean i
i don't see any reason why not so you
would just kind of push up and now he's
gonna they're they're in trouble right
they're in huge trouble yeah and that
would be right now
just as the last thing to kind of
introduce you to
kind of gm level chess right in this
position
i can visualize checkmate in five moves
oh so white starts and delivers track
minor 5 but that's a lot less impressive
than it sounds
and the way that white delivers this
track mate just to kind of inspire you a
little bit there's a
and this is where chess beauty i'll
introduce you to kind of real chess
beauty
you can do stuff that looks impossible
but really is possible because of the
properties of the position that's called
tactics
and in this position taking the pawn is
again like a b-plus kind of move it's a
great move black's in huge trouble
but you can actually do something really
really cunning you can give a check
on g6 right and oh
this looks terrible this you might be
like what what is this guy saying
why right right i am confused by that
one because then the pawn would just
take it and then these guys he's got his
like you know
he's got his front line again and not
only that you've given up your
your queen oh absolutely yes yeah that
would suck too
exactly so but if i try to execute this
move it won't let me for some reason is
this a glitch on the site or
is there a reason it won't let me take
the queen
if you look at the whole board
uh why won't it let you uh
what would be preventing this from
happening
uh i
do not see it okay so
and this has come because in your mind
you're paying attention to the king side
and this side of the board
right and this is kind of an example of
tunnels but take a look at this bishop
that i just highlighted on c4
right and take a look at the diagonal
that it's controlling
does anything jump out at you dude
you're right
[ __ ] yeah so the pl if the pawn did take
the queen then the bishop just wins
that's it
exactly so in the rules of chess it's
illegal to take the queen
notice what is this an application of
which concept that i've introduced you
pinning right exactly the pawn is pinned
and this is the ultimate pin
when not only can the piece not only is
it inadvisable for a piece to
it is literally illegal for the pawn to
move
wow so this queen is immune wow
that's amazing and so black has to move
his king one square to the right
right and now when you capture the pawn
what
additional benefit have you derived from
giving that check preliminarily and then
capturing the plane
uh you have uh basically opened the
maybe just like open the line to open
the uh open the
the rank like by doing that or what am i
what else am i missing here let me see
maybe simpler than you because like if
you compare this position
and this position what is it's like
where's wall it's like what is the only
difference here
there's only one difference
what is the difference there's position
or
this position i feel like i'm missing
something
simple here uh
where's the i'm not sure sorry i don't i
don't know
no no no problem and the really i think
you've seen this it's just like
you're thinking for of something more
complicated it's the position of the
black king that's different
right so look at and and i'm sure you
know this position the king is here
right in this position the king is here
and you might be a big freaking deal
like
what are you saying well right what i'm
saying is that this king is actually in
check right now
so this king in this situation is being
attacked yes
right and so the king has to move one
square to the left right but now if you
compare the two positions in this
situation it is black's turn
and in this situation it is white's turn
right and so by initiating that whole
sequence of the check white has gained
what's called a tempo which really just
means gained an extra move
right is that kind of making sense so
here it's black's turn and black can
involve defensive pieces
to kind of throw water onto the fire
right versus here
white can deliver the deadly blow
because it's his move again
right and this deadly blow comes in the
form of another move that exploits this
pin
which is the move knight to g6 oh
and so if it tries to move back it's
gone
yes and well the pawn cannot take the
knight because again of this man and
white is posing a threat now
that black cannot defend against so
checkmate is innocent imminent innocent
right so maybe you can tell me what and
this will be your first
mate in one puzzle where you basically
look at a position and identify
where the checkmate is let's say black
makes a random move
right can you identify the checkmate in
this position
it is let me see here why
it's not the bishop
if the bishop were to go in no right
that pawn is defended exactly yeah yeah
right that's that
um the knight's only positioning to move
forward would be
would be h8 um but that's not going to
really do anything
it'll lock it into it'll have to force
it down um
and the queen can can zip up to
h a or uh more likely
would it let's see it would be h8 or
would it be
g7 you're almost there so one of these
two squares will give you a hint is
correct
is the checkmating square
oh okay no of course it's uh it's it's
it's h7 of course right because then you
can just hit either one no matter what
so
this square yes is that it no almost
but then i can capture with my king oh
yeah that's an idiot move yes you're
right and the night
is not the night is not the position but
you're almost there you have to put it
on a square where it's guarded by the
night and that's one of the hardest
things to visualize
night defenses because of the unusual
movement of the night
okay so so then in this case basically
so it would be
h8 right so if the king so the king
tried to take the queen
knight gets it if it tried to move away
queen gets it so there's no
there's there's there's no escape
precisely the queen is guarding g7 h7
the king cannot
move on to a pawn so f7 because of the
presence of this pawn
um the king cannot go anywhere so it's
basically entombed by a combination of
its own pieces
and the knight in the queen right and
just the knight and the queen actually
constitute
one of the greatest attacking pairs on
the board the knight and the queen are
have incredible synergy and you can kind
of see why here
it's almost in this scenario yeah it's
like a yo-yo you know the knight is like
the string that is able to extend its
influence and defend the
critical squares where the queen then
jumps onto right
and now a lot of people here would look
at this position and say
oh snap i can take the rook why can take
the rook with this night is this
a good tr based on what we talked about
in the peace value system
is this a desirable trade it's not
really a trade as we'll talk about but
is it a desirable thing to do for white
let's ignore for a second the check mix
is just
if you consider this in a vacuum is this
something you'd want to do
uh no you said the rook is way more
valuable than the night right
okay so would you give up i mean from
white's perspective
would you want to give away a night for
a rook
um
knife oh yes so yeah in general yes that
would make sense correct right
yeah not a trick question exactly you'd
want to give the knife for the rook that
would be
there's a name for that um you have an
extra exchange a night for a roker a
bishop for a rook is called an exchange
not too important but
just for your knowledge right and white
is
how winning is this whites much much
better that's a very serious that's like
five points for three
pretty serious advantage that's being
like two pawns up
right and so your goal then to summarize
in the opening
is to bring your pieces out thank you
it's to bring your pieces out
onto squares where they are doing
something and doing something in your
con
in your terms really normally means
either pinning an opponent's piece
or aiming at your opponent's king or in
some way
in the general vicinity of the center of
the board because then they are able to
control
and contest the most number of squares
right that's true even mathematically if
the knight
is on the rim and there's a there's a
kind of a saying knights on the rim or
grim
it is controlling one two
three four squares right right
controlling just means it can literally
land on four squares
right and if you compare that to the
knight in the center
it's controlling let's count one well
that is not how the knight moves oh that
is neat
i am the worst arrow drawer ever two
three
four five six seven eight
now you might look in is it really
controlling the square it came from
technically yes so it's controlling
eight squares
right and that is a huge you know eight
four who care
that is a huge difference in chess
because the more squares
a piece a piece is controlling the
better it is for these are there
exceptions to that rule
do you ever develop the knight to the
corner absolutely
there are hundreds and thousands of
games where this has been done
successfully not in this position
but there are situations when you are
let's say leading the knight to this
square specifically that's called a
maneuver
when you take a piece from one square
and through
one move or more aim to place it on a
different square
sometimes you need to you know pass a
war zone or you need to pass an awkward
square to reach
a good square and so therefore there are
exceptions to that rule
right um and so
that's why you want to develop your
pieces toward the center of the board
you usually want to talk your king away
and then
again this is not what you always do in
chessbook for purposes
of starting things out you want to find
a way to direct your pieces toward
the side of the board on which your
opponent's king resides
whether that is the middle or normally
it's going to be the king side because
normally your opponents are also going
to castle
right and through the lens of their
first couple of games which i'm warning
you it's going to be tough you know it's
going to be tough to wrap your head
around everything your clock's going to
be ticking
sure but we're going to discuss ways
that you can do that in addition to what
we talked about just now which is
ruining your opponent's bond structure
right turn into ruins got it got it
yeah which is basically what you're
gonna do on my dad